[Musique]
Vincent vignerons bonjour bonjour nous
vous recevons aujourd'hui en direct pour
une chaîne Youtube qui s'appelle
thinkerview vous représentez
l'association adrastia qui s'occupe sur
les questions d'épuisement de ressources
de trajectoire sociétal qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire
c'est
une petite association qui a trois ans
d'existence qui a été créée en juin 2014
qui est une initiative citoyenne c'est
important à situer parce que même si
bien sûr nous faisons appel aux experts
et que nous lisons la littérature des
climatologues des énergéticiens des
spécialistes en matière première etc
nous l'association n'est pas constituée
d'experts moi-même je n'ai pas une
formation en climatologie ou en énergie
par contre
l'initiative est née de citoyens
inquiets qui commençait à intuiter ou à
comprendre que les choses n'allaient pas
aussi bien que on va dire le discours
menus stream sur l'évolution de
l'humanité le laisser entendre et le
laisser présager et c'est vraiment un
ensemble de citoyens qui s'est rencontré
grâce à des réseaux Internet grâce à
Internet et qui a choisi à partir de
littérature commune enfin de lecture
commune de se fédérer autour de cette
question là
avec comme mission principale de
partager l'information
c'est vraiment l'objet de l'information
l'objet de l'association c'est à dire
que nous considérons que le plus gros
pas à faire pour envisager une
transition et une adaptation à cette
inquiétude que nous avons sur l'avenir
de l'humanité
consiste d'abord en la circulation de
l'information sur ce sujet précis donc
adresse les choses alors ça a fait débat
assez souvent avant de poser ce que pose
à drastien quel background vous avez
vous êtes le président de cette
association titre personnel comment se
compose votre conseil d'administration
d'accord
le conseil d'administration je vais
préciser tout à l'heure à titre
personnel j'ai une formation de
psychologie clinique que je n'ai pas
terminé j'ai donc l'équivalent d'un
Master 1 une maîtrise à l'époque j'étais
pas forcément très scolaire donc c'était
la raison de cette séparation en bonne
en bon terme
j'ai travaillé dans le bâtiment par la
suite j'ai travaillé dans le domaine des
travaux sur corde donc c'est les gars
qui travaillent sur les bâtiments en
tout cas c'était ma discipline comme les
alpinistes vous connaissez Gilles
Babinet peut-être non
je connais pas personnellement
je suis pas moi-même issu de l'escalade
c'était vraiment une rencontre fortuite
qui m'a fait faire ce métier il se
trouve qu'à ce moment là j'étais un peu
grimpeur mais amateur et à ce moment là
j'étais par contre très manuel et le
côté manuel est besoin de confrontation
en réel ça m'a mené aussi à Grasse pour
elle développer un peu plus loin et en
parallèle de ce parcours à la fois de
recherche fondamentale sur l'humain à
partir de la psychologie clinique et en
même temps le contact avec la réalité
voilà c'est ces deux pans de ma vie
personnelle mon fait m'inquiéter ou en
tout cas d'abord me questionner sur la
nature humaine sur son rapport à
l'environnement c'est ça la question
fondamentale que je me posais déjà ado
en fait question assez classique et le
croisement entre une expérience de
terrain et la théorie vraiment le
l'humain tel qu'il est décrit par
lui-même
m'a fait conclure dans des travaux
personnels que j'avais commencé il y a
une vingtaine d'années à sortir de
l'adolescence
de façon tout à fait théorique presque
philosophique j'ai écrit des modèles un
modèle en particulier qui concluait dans
dans son développement que l'humanité
possède dans sa nature en son sein dans
son dans sa structure même adaptative le
risque d'autodestruction
et donc j'ai développé ce travail il a
été publié mais longtemps mis de côté
accepter en tant que modèle par un
certain nombre de un certain nombre de
lecteurs capables de juger le nom de la
maladie de la validité parce que mon
modèle n'est pas forcément valide mais
en tout cas de la justesse du
questionnement il est possible en effet
que la nature que l'humain possède dans
sa nature propre le risque
d'autodestruction
et j'ai décidé autour de 2009 2010 de
quitter mon emploi dans le dans les
travaux sur corde j'étais responsable
d'agence à l'époque
j'ai lu les données c'est là où je me
suis donc questionné sur les modèles
existants sur la théorie scientifique
sur
l'énergie sur le rapport entre l'énergie
et le climat sur le lien entre l'énergie
et l'économie j'ai accumulé les données
un peu je pense qu'on a un peu tous les
mêmes les mêmes lectures les mêmes
ressources
et j'ai décidé de sortir de
l'abstraction pour moi et de partager
cette information là c'est là qu'elle va
se tiré donc en 2014 est-ce que c'est le
rapport du Club de Rome qui vous a mis
un peu la puce à l'oreille ou est-ce que
c'est une littérature ou une
filmographie bien particulière
alors j'ai certainement eu une
imprégnation culturelle forte sur la
question mais tout jeune je pense à
l'histoire sans fin voilà par exemple
ce film là que j'ai vu à l'école
primaire est terriblement angoissant
pour un enfant c'est le néant qui arrive
qui balaye tout l'existence et
probablement que oui une certaine
imprégnation culturelle par la fiction à
la science-fiction je suis un grand fan
de Star Trek voilà
ce qui m'intéressait très vite c'est les
paradoxes exactement les paradoxes entre
les espoirs et la réalité de ces espoirs
comment il se réalise ou pas
et commence surtout et là on va pouvoir
peut-être en venir à mon travail
personnel et mes réflexions sur une
théorie écologique de l'esprit comment
l'humain compose avec ses contradictions
en particulier ces contradictions
écologiques mais c'est et les écueils
écologiques auxquelles il se confronte
le conseil d'administration de votre
assaut alors bon il a évolué récemment
je pourrais pas ce soir vous en dire
plus
parce que c'est quelque chose qui est
fait qui est tacté mais qui n'est pas
rendu public mais donc il est constitué
essentiellement de citoyens voilà qui
sont pas experts et on peut trouver une
preuve d'anglais on peut trouver une
prof unique professeure universitaire en
informatique on peut trouver un cheminot
on peut trouver un photographe enfin
voilà dans le conseil d'administration
ce sont des personnes qui
qui ont pour ambition vraiment alors
bien sûr de partager la formation mais
d'accueillir les paroles les témoignages
et les émotions des gens qui traversent
voilà la réalisation de leurs
inquiétudes le fait que la réalité
confirme leurs inquiétudes c'est un peu
prise de conscience cette prise de
conscience là c'est très important pour
nous d'être disponible pour ça parce
qu'évidemment c'est pas une réalité
facile donc on va pas avoir le temps de
déléguer toute votre chaîne Youtube
parce que vous avez une chaîne Youtube
votre association à une chaîne Youtube
ou vous donner des conférences
pas trop mal ficelées d'ailleurs avec
des bonnes sources
qui qui déploie en fait votre
raisonnement par rapport à la
consommation des ressources l'épuisement
des ressources la démographie mondiale
la consommation de charbon la
consommation de nucléaires du mois de
d'uranium on va plus s'attaquer
maintenant sur la fin de votre prisme de
lecture et la mise en oeuvre peut-être
de solutions ou de préconisations est-ce
que vous disséminez ou est-ce que vous
essayez des préconisations sur
ce néon pour vous qui arrive
c'est un point très souvent discuté chez
adrastia puisque nous nous interdisons
presque l'utilisation du mot solution
on en plaisante en interne on dit que le
celui qui dit solution il engage parce
que on considère que contre on va dire
en résumé ce que la science je vais
reprendre un petit peu l'objet de
l'association
qui a été discuté on considère que on va
dire la chute de la civilisation
industrielle et pour nous inéluctable et
ce terme inéluctable est très fort
mais on a fait un choix lors de la
création de l'association c'est de
croire ce que la science c'est
et ça c'est évidemment discutable on
peut continuer à ergoter ou négocier sur
les savoirs scientifiques nous on a fait
le choix de considérer que la on va dire
la fin des ressources c'est à dire
l'impossibilité pour quoi que ce soit de
croître dans un environnement fini et
sur allez
dès son jetés en quelque sorte et en
plus nous nous retrouvons à cette
période de l'existence humaine ou les
dessonchetés et cette fois d'une façon
totale d'autres civilisations se sont
effondrées avant nous mais elles ont
ré-énergie ou d'autres civilisations
aurait émergé à partir d'autres sources
d'approvisionnement etc aujourd'hui la
problématique est planétaire et les
dégâts sont
ne serait-ce que sur la limite des
ressources en fait la question est
réglée en quelque sorte mais en plus
nous avons des impacts climatiques et
des dérèglements
biologique même qui nous touche déjà et
qui sont encore plus inquiétants
donc vous ne donnez pas de
préconisations alors ça n'est pas tout à
fait la même chose le dire qu'il n'y a
pas de solution c'est pas dire du tout
qu'il ne faut rien faire et ça ça a
beaucoup fait débat aussi
ne rien faire ça voudrait dire soit le
statut co absolu ou même ce goberger de
la société telle qu'elle est consommé à
fond etc pas du tout une préconisation
qu'on fait
on ne considère pas qu'il faut non plus
rester les bras croisés même si on
regarde le monde de façon consciente ça
suffira pas non plus il y a de quantité
et quantité d'aménagement à faire
il est vrai qu'à drastia reste encore
beaucoup dans l'information parce qu'on
considère que cette information là est
primordiale avant de mettre des
aménagements en place on parle
d'aménagement et pas de solution alors
je me permets de faire une petite
promotion pour des vidéos qui sont
sorties hier aujourd'hui d'avenir
climatique qui est une association
essentiellement composée d'étudiants de
jeunes qui ont fait 4 ou 4 ou 5 petites
séquences très pédagogiques très claires
exactement sur les données dont par la
drastia et qui sont sur la même logique
alors eux utilisent un peu plus le même
le terme solution
mais ils sont sur évidemment la sobriété
qui est pourrait être une préconisation
mais on pourra mettre quand même
certaines réserves sur la possibilité
d'une sobriété sobriété énergétique de
consommation de façon c'est la même
chose et ben c'est ça que c'est ça notre
réserve si vous voulez nous on fait le
lien direct grâce à l'équation de kayak
tout ce que vous connaissez grâce au
cours très brillant de Jean-Marc
Jancovici on connaît le lien entre
l'énergie et le PIB donc le lien entre
on va dire la valeur de l'argent qu'on a
sur nos comptes et l'impact que cet
argent a sur l'environnement
et et on sait aussi que le PIB c'est le
moyen pour chaque pays chaque nation de
se défendre économiquement et
stratégiquement géopolite politiquement
donc ce que nous craignons dans
l'association c'est que nous soyons en
quelque sorte dans une situation un peu
inextricable
parce que évidemment il faut il faut
promouvoir la sobriété c'est une
évidence
l'économie l’économie n'est pas taillée
pour ça c'est une fonction exponentielle
quand vous quand vous préconisez une
sobriété c'est à dire une baisse de
consommation donc une baisse dans
l'accélération de croissance
le système financier qu'est-ce qui fait
quand on lui applique ce type de facteur
il va s'en défendre par tous les moyens
évidemment et
ne serait-ce que par la circulation de
l'information sur
comment dire
mais en fait la question n'est même pas
sur comment le système va récupérer
l'information qui lui est donnée la
question est vraiment pour moi d'ordre
psycho-anthropologique et on va dire
il faut à mon sens il faut réfléchir à
notre position d'humain dans notre
écosystème en tant qu'espèce comment
notre espèce a fait pour partir du genre
Romo et de finir par être la seule à
irriter de se foisonnement de du mal du
manoïde du même du
oui pas du mal de dominer
nous sommes les seuls héritiers des
hominidés des Hominines
pourquoi et pourquoi systématiquement
lorsque nous avons acquis une compétence
cognitive particulière psychologique
particulière cela manifestement a eu on
va dire une corrélation pour l'instant
avec des dégâts écologiques la question
qui se pose peut-être aujourd'hui et que
je travaille dans certains de mes
ouvrages
c'est comment l'humain se construit
psychiquement et psychologiquement en
fonction de son interaction avec
l'environnement
alors c'est pour ça que je suis réservé
à dire le système va récupérer le
système financier va récupérer il y a
aussi quelque chose de potentiellement
intrinsèque à notre existence sur cette
planète je vais donner une grande
trajectoire
à l'issue
avant l'Holocène ou à la période où nous
étions encore des chasseurs-cueilleurs
la capacité de charge de la planète
Terre
avec un impact de l'humanité sur la
planète qui existait mais qui était
relativement modeste tout à fait
compatible avec une soutenabilité
l'humanité c'était 5 millions maximum
d'être humain
on peut imaginer on peut supposer que la
soutenabilité et la capacité de charge à
la planète Terre c'est dans des
conditions écologiques à peu près
stables 5 millions d'humains on peut se
questionner sur
ce qu'a apporté la civilisation en
termes démographique
et sur ce lien fort qui existe entre 7
milliards 495 millions d'humains qui
existent désormais et l'ensemble des
dégradations écologiques qui ont permis
à ces humains d'exister depuis la
période où nous étions encore des
chasseurs le chiffre de 5 millions vous
le donnez d'où c'est alors il faut lire
des scholas c'est n'importe d'entrée sur
sur naturalisme en particulier voilà
je lis la littérature alors
pardonnez-moi si je ne me souviens pas
des noms des auteurs parce que je lis
les articles en anglais j'essaie de les
traduire je suis pas très bon en anglais
je l'ai traduit par contre mon dernier
ouvrage si me permettait mon dernier
transition 2017
source ces données là
à la limite 5 millions peu importe nous
étions très peu nombreux je peux vous
donner ça vous connaissez chiffres vous
connaissez ces chiffres
nous étions 500 millions à peu près
d'humains au 16e siècle nous étions 200
millions en l'an 0 à peu près voilà et
cette croissance démographique est aussi
liée à une quantité d'impact par
l'agriculture par le développement des
techniques et puis plus récemment par
rapport énergétique donc vous connaissez
aussi le lien
avec les hydrocarbures etc qui a permis
d'exploiter encore plus l'agriculture et
la développer qu'en plus encore donc
pour vous le plus gros star de
l'humanité c'est de ne pas comprendre la
fonction exponentielle
je ne sais même pas si il y a
possibilité même en comprenant
de s'adapter en fonction d'elle
voilà la question que je pose
aujourd'hui alors je vais préciser
quelque chose il y a des questions qui
appartiennent à l'association
internationale
il y a des questions qui concerne les
modèles et là on est plutôt sur des
réflexions que je me pose moi qui
peuvent recouper le choix d'adrastia
mais pas nécessairement adresse une
association indépendante même si je la
préside son seul travail c'est de faire
de l'information sur le risque
d'effondrement vous nous avez dit que
vous vous étiez penché sur la
psychologie humaine par rapport à la
perception des problèmes est-ce que vous
êtes intéressé à la psychologie de la
upper class
c'était un petit peu ce que je voulais
introduire précédemment
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation
où quel que soit les stratégies que nous
avons développées aucune la fonction
moi l'hypothèse que je pose dans mes
travaux
je me permets de vous couper aucunement
fonctionner sur la fin dans le monde la
fin dans le monde baisse on a toujours
800 800 millions de crève la fin depuis
1950 le chiffre n'a pas bougé on était
censé baisser le chiffre des graves la
fin à 400 millions c'était les objectifs
du millénaire à partir de l'an 2000 on
est toujours à 800 millions de la fin
mais on a quand même évolué on est en
train de manier maintenant des
technologies comme l'intelligence
artificielle comme
toutes ces nouvelles technologies pour
nous affranchir de certaines contraintes
basses contraintes que l'humanité a
toujours cultivé pour vous c'est un
échec
sur le plan écologique
nous avons passé des seuils qui montrent
que quoi qu'il se passe demain il y a
des choses irréparables de la même façon
que quand vous cuisez un peu trop votre
gâteau et qu'il est noirci vous ne
pourrez jamais récupérer les ingrédients
pour en faire un autre le principe
d'irréversibilité s'applique aussi au
dégâts que nous avons fait sur
l'environnement quel que soit les
technologies que nous déployons
désormais ou les moyens que nous
déplarons désormais c'est à dire que le
contexte d'adaptation c'est pour ça que
nous n'utilisons pas solution le
contexte d'adaptation dans lequel nous
allons nous plonger c'est un contexte où
malheureusement les choses vont être
pire dans notre environnement donc quoi
que nous mettrions en place elles
devront s'adapter elles-mêmes à cette
augmentation des problèmes
revenons à la psychologie de la
upperclass
cette psychologie de la upperclass que
je connais moins bien que vous pour être
très clair vous imaginez que je connais
là je pense que c'est votre terrain
culturel c'est un voilà et ben non c'est
vrai
nous sommes des passagers clandestins il
me semblait aussi non ce qui m'intéresse
moi c'est d'essayer de comprendre
je vais cadrer un petit peu mon travail
se situe entre la psychologie du
développement on va dire Piaget depuis
Piaget et tout ce qui s'est fait après
mise à jour
les nouveaux modèles de la psychologie
bayésienne les modèles bayésiens de la
perception cognition
et en particulier le naturalisme de
Descola
et ce qui m'intéresse de comprendre
c'est comment l'espèce humaine donc là
vous retrouverez aussi des références à
yoval Noah hahari qui considère en
lisant l'anthropologie à partir de 70000
ans il s'est passé une espèce de
révolution cognitive
qui fait que sapiens donc le dernier
héritier de son grand Jean homo s'est
retrouvé avec des capacités à mon sens
qui sont celles-ci de se raconter des
histoires
qui se substitue à la réalité perçue
comme si elles étaient la réalité perçue
un peu comme la religion la religion
fait partie de ces histoires toutes les
mythologies font partie de cette
histoire là à mon sens ce sont c'est une
capacité psychologique cognitive qui a
permis à l'humanité de substituer une
réalité par une autre et de s'adapter à
cette réalité là plutôt qu'à la réalité
perçue expliquez le nez et d'expliquer
tous toutes les questions existentielles
d'ailleurs à mon sens l'humanité se
retrouvait complètement abandonnée par
la vie elle lui a donné des tas de
capacités l'évolution à donner des
quantités de capacité à la vie et puis
la laisser comme ça se débrouiller seul
à impacter l'environnement elle-même il
y a se mettre en péril elle-même déjà
très tôt ça c'est des choses qui sont
répertoriées les traces sédimentaires
montrent que en Afrique bien avant la
civilisation le fait de couper les
forêts ça laissait des impacts
géologiques
en Europe les forêts étaient brûlées
massivement à moins 20.000 ans bien
avant la civilisation par des
chasseurs-cueilleurs c'est ça la
question
donc ma question mon mon angle d'attaque
pour en revenir à le parclass c'est
d'essayer de comprendre comment
l'humanité en s'écrivant des histoires
qui expliquait son désarroi existentiel
elle a eu besoin d'inventer des nouveaux
codes de loi des mythologies des
religions mais aussi de trouver des
causes à son existence et en particulier
des causes à ces problèmes
causes à ces problèmes qu'il la mettait
déjà en péril c'est à dire que quand on
fait brûler une forêt massivement
potentiellement on n'a pas de pompiers à
-20 000 ans et personne peut éteindre le
feu donc c'est une c'est un risque même
si le bénéfice ensuite c'est de
faciliter les déplacements la cueillette
et la chasse bien sûr c'est pour ça que
c'est fort a été brûlées il n'empêche
que c'était aussi un risque existentiel
on pourrait parler de l'épopée de
Gilgamesh dans laquelle un roi décide de
construire une cité magnifique mais pour
ça il a besoin de couper une forêt de
cèdre absolument merveilleuse et c'est
là où je voulais en venir c'est que dans
les hypothèses que je pose il est
possible que parmi les capacités
intrinsèques à l'humanité celles-ci soit
apparue c'est celle de la substitution
causale
c'est celle d'attribuer à quelqu'un
d'autre que soi la responsabilité d'acte
qu'on fait soi-même
c'est une hypothèse de travail mais qui
m'intéresse beaucoup pour en revenir à
votre questionnement de tout à l'heure
par rapport à l'opperclass
ce qui nous dirige ce qui nous dirige
ou ceux qui font du business sur notre
tête exactement
et je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure des 5
millions d'humains peu importe 5 si
c'est trois six la question n'est pas là
nous sommes partis de quelques millions
d'humains la civilisation s'est
développée avec toutes les inégalités et
les injustices qu'on connaît
mais cette virgule 490 et quelques
millions d'humains il y a pardon
n'aurait pas pu exister
cette
n'aurait pas pu exister sans ces progrès
techniques qui ont aussi causé des
dégâts ma question c'est de savoir si
dans ce mouvement évolutif là ne s'est
pas construit aussi la possibilité
permanente de se dégager soit de son
impact écologique en accusant quelqu'un
d'autre que soi pourquoi c'est très
important ce mouvement cognitif
parce que quand on coupe une forêt
on est responsable de ce que les humains
savent depuis toujours c'est que ça crée
de l'érosion que ça met en péril les
villages qui sont en dessous ça l'humain
le sait depuis très longtemps donc il
faut absolument expliquer ça par un
autre que celui qui fait l'acte ok donc
la upper classe là on est en train de
dire voilà on a trouvé un seul coupable
c'est la hupper classe ou c'est nous
c'est ça votre possible votre posture
l'hypothèse c'est de dire que toutes les
classes
trouve toujours une justification à
leurs actions
c'est une hypothèse mais ce qui
m'intéresse c'est justement en quoi elle
s'articule avec l'exponentielle que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure
parce que elle a toujours et c'est une
constante en fait dans toutes les
mythologies effectivement la cité ou la
population la communauté qui écrit son
histoire va aussi désigner le coupable à
tous à tous ces à tous ces torts et à
toutes ces difficultés
ça fait partie de la mythologie est-ce
que la l'hypothèse de la substitution
causale et entendable pour expliquer en
quoi l'humanité a non seulement divergé
les autres êtres vivants
mais aussi expliquer cette divergence et
optimiser cette divergence en facilitant
les actions
tu sais que vous vous intéressez
beaucoup à la question du terrorisme
comment nos sociétés se sont construites
collectivement culturellement
en préparant en quelque sorte la
justification au manque de légitimité
potentielle ça doit vous faire écho par
rapport à le beurre classe
comment nos sociétés en leur sein la
possibilité de dire quand il y a un
problème c'est lui
et ça c'est potentiellement quelque
chose qui est qui fait partie
intrinsèquement de la culture humaine de
la construction des objets de culture à
partir des objets perçus
pour ça je m'intéresse à Descola
au naturalisme à l'animisme et à
l'analogie et autotémisme parce que
voilà démission la démission de la
responsabilité de tous si je peux me
permettre d'un résumé trivialement votre
point de vue tout le monde est
démissionnaire c'est ça on peut le dire
comme ça
c'est très important par rapport au
contexte d'aujourd'hui
parce que ok donc est-ce que c'est une
là je vais toucher mes mots là attention
est-ce que c'est une catatonie
émotionnelle est-ce que c'est un déni
généralisé
est-ce que c'est comme sur le Titanic
c'est à dire que la peur classe dit
c'est le Titanic vous inquiétez pas
continuer à border cool les gars fait
jouer le piano puis il y a la middle
club qui se dit bon
la upperclass bouge pas donc forcément
c'est bon et puis il y a la troisième
classe qui commence à taper au barreau
en disant montrez-nous comment on fait
pour construire des radeaux parce qu'il
y en a pas assez pour tout le monde ça
c'est ma première question la deuxième
question c'est qu'est-ce que vous
anticipez vous anticipez un génocide un
Holocaust parce que quand je regarde les
quand je regarde les courbes
ça fait beaucoup de milliards qui
risquent de décroître d'un coup sur une
période de temps qui est à l'échelle
d'une ou deux générations
est-ce que vous anticipez ça est-ce que
vous anticipez des familles des
épidémies un transfert d'épidémie de
part des flux migratoires liés au
réchauffement climatique à des gays
ces petites choses délicates votre
prisme de lecture finale c'est quoi
c'est ça la première pour la première
partie de la question
et ça rejoint ce que je vous explique
par rapport à la psychologie humaine on
va de toute façon ne rien faire avant le
mur je pense c'est à dire que l'homme
français réagit toujours quand il
commence à avoir de l'eau à la moitié
des narines c'est ça c'est à craindre
mais en fait la réponse nous l'avons
puisque le pic énergétique en tout cas
pour le pétrole conventionnel nous
passons là d'accord ça n'est pas été
anticipé
depuis 72 alors conceptuellement mais
pas en termes adaptatif pour notre
société est-ce que vous connaissez le
proverbe dans le renseignement qui dit
on a le droit de se faire on a le droit
de perdre mais pas de se faire
surprendre est-ce que vous pensez que
l'État n'a pas bossé sur ce sujet là
alors les états ça fait partie de
l'article que je crois vous avez lu je
pense que l'information elle est là elle
est là depuis très longtemps les États
sont font appel aux scientifiques depuis
le depuis que la question de la fin des
ressources et la science se sont
rencontrées début du 19e parce que vous
avez identifié des mesures proactives de
ces états honnêtement je n'y ai pas
accès donc ma réponse je ne sais pas
je me doute centre de gestion de crise
qui a été enterré en plein Paris au
10ème niveau non fraîchement construit
n'ayant pas les informations précises je
ne peux pas me prononcer je ne le ferai
pas mais je n'ai pas de doute sur le
fait que l'information existe à cet
endroit là
en période insurrectionnel et qu'il y
ait tout un tas d'interfaces qui
permettent que le fait que cette
information soit connue ne soit pas
connue de tous
d'accord quel que soit les stratagèmes
de communication de politique
ça c'est une chose ça ne veut pas dire
pour autant que ce que je disais sur la
décharge de responsabilité tout à
l'heure n'est pas valable c'est-à-dire
que l'aveuglement est aussi un mouvement
lorsque nous avons consommé tout au long
du 20e siècle nous n'avons pas
uniquement eu le fusil sur la tempe
c'est ce que je voulais dire tout à
l'heure il y a quand même une espèce de
co-construction de ce système
pour la deuxième partie de la question
nous avons je pense les mêmes
inquiétudes que vous sur les nombreuses
les passagers clandestins par contre
et toujours pour en revenir à la
psychologie et aux émotions humaines je
parlais tout à l'heure de modèle byésien
nous avons la capacité
héritée de l'évolution à anticiper
l'avenir en fonction du passé c'est
trivial mais c'est quelque chose qui est
neurologiquement inscrit
et c'est aussi ce qui est un verrou
adaptatif c'est à dire que le présent
qui s'affiche à nous nous le connaissons
qu'à partir de son passé et le passé ne
dit rien d'un avenir qui ne peut pas
être connu ça c'est l'écoulement
linéaire du temps
c'est physique
donc nous allons anticiper l'avenir à
partir de notre culture notre culture et
celle d'une croissance la culture on va
dire occidentale c'est pas la culture du
monde mais elle domine culture
occidentale et celle d'une croissance
exponentielle très rapide avec une très
forte emprise une très forte destruction
et une interprétation totalement fausse
du concept de compétition
qui est la compétition c'est la guerre
c'est la violence c'est la domination
etc
la sélection naturelle c'est autre chose
la sélection naturelle c'est la théorie
de l'évolution et c'est notre vous
faites pas de social darwinisme
si mais avec une acception de
compétition issue de la science pas
issue de l'interprétation culturelle
la compétition
la raison pour laquelle nous allons nous
battre demain peut donner deux choses le
chaos la violence la guerre mais comme
cela c'est déjà produit dans l'évolution
peut donner des stratégies de ce
solidarité parfaitement efficace dans un
contexte de compétition
parce que il faudra aussi optimiser la
circulation des ressources et que
potentiellement ceux qui le feront le
mieux dans la plus grande solidarité
seront meilleurs que d'autres qui auront
cette exception corrompue du concept de
compétition et qui sortiront en premier
les armes pour revenir à la psychologie
de la vapeur classe de la classe
dirigeante
est-ce que vous avez essayé de vous
mettre à leur place par exemple
mettez-vous à la place d'Emmanuel Macron
Emmanuel Macron notre président qui a
accès à tout un tas de notes de certains
services ou de l'armée l'armée
s'intéresse beaucoup à ces questions
d'épuisement de ressources surtout au
collège intermède défense du moins
l'école de guerre ils ont changé la
terminologie
un peu comme les japonais avec leur
armée c'est une armée de défense puis là
il pense à remettre une armée
notre président
quelle est sa marge de manœuvre
si je devais caricaturer je dirais que
ça n'est pas lui qui dit qui décide qui
décide
l'espèce pardonnez-moi je reviens
là-dessus
les positions de chacun dans la société
sont des héritages
[Musique]
on va dire le politique sélectionne ce
dont il a besoin dans le substrat de la
société en ce moment la société pour
tout un tas de raisons de déni de
réalité mais en place des gouvernants
plutôt faciles à manipuler et qui
suivent on va dire ce qui serait utile
selon la croyance justement d'une
compétition absolument féroce et
dominante qui devra mettre en place des
pouvoirs autoritaires etc nous restons
dans ce schéma là
ce qui domine c'est la compétition
économique l'emprise sur les ressources
donc l'influence que un pays peut avoir
sur tel autre pays qui possède ses
ressources qu'il n'a pas faut rappeler
par exemple
que l'Europe vous me confirmerez à un
peu de charbon de l'agriculture mais
rien d'autre
et on a des idées mais c'est tout donc
en place au pouvoir il y a des personnes
qui font l'interface entre la nécessité
pour l'Europe de garder une puissance
très importante sur le plan économique
même si elle est totalement artificielle
financière par exemple parce que
l'Europe si elle n'a pas cette place là
artificielle n'a rien pour être autonome
et chaque pays encore moins
indépendamment l'Europe quand vous jouez
au risque le risque j'ai pas chaud
souvent mais l'Europe c'est le pire
endroit après
bon
je je voudrais vous poser la question
est-ce que pour vous la démocratie
est liée à une consommation énergétique
on prend on prend par exemple l'exemple
de la Corée du Nord où il y a de la
famille nous 40% de la population étant
en star en état de famine constante ils
ont pas de démocratie
on prend des pays occidentaux les plus
belles démocraties les démocraties
nordiques ils ont une consommation
énergétique relativement importante ou
des ressources énergétiques importantes
est-ce que vous pensez à ma question du
moins la réponse un peu dans la question
est-ce que quand la baisse énergétique
ils vont la baisse de consommation
énergétique des populations occidentales
va s'effectuer selon vos modèles
est-ce que toutes les démocraties vont
sauter
il se trouve que dans le dernier ouvrage
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure transition
2017 je fais quelques paragraphes sur ce
que je pense être la démocratie dans ce
contexte justement
psycho évolutionniste
l'exploitation des ressources c'est ce
qui affranchit l'humanité des limites
environnementales des contraintes
environnementales plus cette
exploitation est grande plus l'humanité
les humains peuvent s'abstraire du réel
et inventer des concepts farfelus comme
celui de liberté par exemple pourquoi la
liberté se farfelue la liberté ça
n'existe nulle part ailleurs que dans
l'esprit humain c'est quelque chose de
totalement construit
bon c'est mon point de vue que je
défends je pourrais pas développer là
mais c'est une Arte c'est un artifice si
vous voulez pour moi par contre comme je
le disais tout à l'heure il fait partie
de nos mythologies collective et qui
nous permettent comme je l'expliquais de
justifier notre emprise sur le monde et
les guerres se font au nom de la liberté
strictement
la démocratie
comme je l'expliquais tout à l'heure
pour moi c'est une forme d'optimisation
de la décharge de responsabilité
nos pays ont une empreinte écologique
sur le monde avec les billets que chaque
citoyen utilise c'est ça la valeur de
l'emprunté écologique sur le monde c'est
le billet c'est pas le bulletin de vote
le bulletin de vote pour moi est une
construction de substitution d'une
réalité d'emprise par une autre qui est
un artifice auquel on croit une croyance
la démocratie
la question que vous posez c'est est-ce
qu'en contexte de déclin de chute de la
civilisation les croyances vont tomber
c'est possible et peut-être que la
démocratie partira avec
c'est possible
c'est fun
oui mais c'est contextualisable donc la
démocratie est un épiène
c'est au même titre ou même titre que la
consommation exponentielle d'énergie il
se trouve qu'en plus conceptuellement ça
peut tenir mais c'est peut-être faux
mais il se trouve qu'en plus quand on
regarde l'histoire il y a un lien et on
pourrait même relier ça à l'apparition
des religions morales il y a des études
qui sont faites qui lient qui sont
discuta toutes les discutables qui lie
l'apparition des régies les religions
morales c'est-à-dire celles qui sont
capables vraiment de casser le lien de
la communauté avec la loi naturelle qui
écrivent une autre loi de substitution
il y a un lien entre l'apparition
d'ailleurs sur toute la bande entre
l'Europe et l'Asie simultané et ce lien
là est fait avec la le taux de retour
énergétique de l'agriculture il n'y a
pas sage d'un seuil à un moment donné au
même moment à peu près
et à ce moment-là les grandes religions
morales apparaissent la révolution
Axelle axiale et dans ce schéma là il y
a un lien pour moi entre la psychologie
et les mites que les que l'humain se
fait donc la démocratie fait partie qui
est peut-être ce qui se met en place
dans nos mythologie quand on nous avons
un apport énergétique considérable ou
considérablement ou un très grand nombre
d'esclaves par exemple voilà il y a pour
moi un lien très fort
alors une petite question de du chat
alors je la lis après le déclin de la
société virgule il y aura quoi point
d'interrogation vous avez des pistes sur
ce qui risque d'arriver ou ce qui risque
de fortement en arriver c'est là où je
vais complètement séparer le travail
d'adresseur ne se prononce pas sur ce
sujet-là son travail c'est d'expliquer
ce qui peut se passer ou ce qui va se
passer d'ouvrir le débat sur la période
de transition la chute de la
civilisation il faut informer la
population sur ce sujet là ok mais il
faut dire les choses quand même après
est-ce que si on si on suit votre modèle
si je peux me permettre de résumer
trivialement ça va être une de
boucherie
alors du coup je reviens sur cette
période là il y a aussi l'hypothèse que
la descente énergétique soit si rapide
qu'il soit contre-productif de se taper
dessus
ça coûte cher en énergie une guerre et
on ne la lance que si on peut la
rentabiliser à terme les banques ne
prêteront pas à des pays entiers qui
voudront se battre s'il n'y a pas
possibilité de rembourser l'emprunt et
ça ça peut verrouiller la mise en place
d'une violence à grande échelle aucun
emprunner remboursable tous les autres
sont pas remontables dans tout ça c'est
une illusion mais l'illusion pourrait ne
plus tenir c'est ça que je veux dire au
point que les banques ne prennent plus
pour aller taper juste sans rien
derrière qui ne pourrait même plus
maintenir l'illusion c'est ça que je
veux dire
alors une Grande Guerre mondiale moi j'y
crois pas par contre de la violence
comme ça s'est passé dans les années 90
en Russie de rue de la violence juste
par le dénuement la fin ça c'est
beaucoup plus probable et c'est
probablement même ce qu'on voit déjà
arrivé
il semblerait que le nous ayons passé le
cap ou l'humanité recommence à avoir
faim le
nombre de personnes qui avaient fait un
baisser jusqu'à présent et commencerait
à remonter
c'est probablement là où va se trouver
la plus forte régulation bien avant la
violence peut-être c'est en tout cas une
possibilité
notre question
là je répondais par rapport à drastia
qui ne se prononce pas sur ce qui a rat
après
mais dans mon travail à moi je pose
l'hypothèse que ça soit aussi la fin
tout court
à échéance x pas à table mais là je dis
pas ça par l'armisme je dis ça dans la
lignée d'un jean Josel par exemple qui
est un qui a rapporté les voilà qui
rapportent les les rapports du GIAC qui
était plutôt optimiste plutôt voilà bon
enfant sur le climat jusqu'à cette année
jusqu'à il y a deux ans et qui
maintenant depuis cette année depuis
quelques mois dit clairement que nous
allons aller entre 3 et 5 degrés à la
fin du siècle quoi qu'il arrive
3 5 degrés à la fin du siècle en moyenne
mondiale c'est 6 à 10 degrés sur les
continents parce qu'il fait plus chaud
sur les continents qu'en moyenne mondial
il n'y a aucune agriculture qui résiste
à 6 à 10 degrés de moyenne à la fin du
siècle aucune
alors question
que faire
je te prierai je vais être sérieux
que faire si on décide d'arrêter d'être
spectateur
on se regroupe on fait planter des
petits légumes à 90% d'eau sur son
balcon
on plante un peu partout comme à Cuba ou
on fait quoi on sent on sent part de ce
qui nous reste de démocratie pour
demander des choses on fait quoi je
pense que là nous allons nous confronter
je suis un peu navré d'avoir été si dur
là vous avez pas été dur là c'est soft
encore oui bien sûr mais vous connaissez
quelqu'un qui s'appelle Michael Rupert
oui j'ai il a terminé sa vie parce que
c'était très dur pour lui il a terminé
sa vie c'est suicidé dans sa caravane
avec un poignard 35 cm c'est ça
c'est pour ça que je
trouve que voilà j'ai été dur annoncé
que potentiellement à l'agriculture
n'est pas tenable à la fin du siècle
c'est très dur
et
nous allons nous confronter en fait
voilà ce que je voudrais dire nous nous
confrontons un problème écologique mais
cause allemand c'est pas ce qui se passe
nous confrontons un problème existentiel
qui cause un problème écologique
notre angoisse existentielle elle a
peut-être 300 000 ans d'âge au moment où
nos premiers ancêtres sont apparus en
tant que sapiens et eux déjà avaient un
impact majeur sur l'environnement c'est
eux et le genre Homo en fait
l'anthropologie le montre bien
maintenant tout le genre Homo depuis 3
millions d'années a commencé à déréguler
l'apport d'énergie à son profit au
détriment des autres espèces la grande
mégaphone n'a pas disparu du jour au
lendemain il y a 10 000 ans elle a
disparu progressivement au cours des
trois dernières millions d'années et
avec une accélération au cours des 100
derniers milliers d'années
et cette angoisse que nous avons que
nous portons nous depuis si longtemps
c'est ça que nous traitons c'est une
angoisse ou c'est une perte de confiance
par rapport aux
innovations humaines parce que est-ce
que pour vous la science et la
technologie vont nous sauver
j'ai commencé en disant que
nous avions fait le choix de croire en
ce que la science c'est
la science ne nous sauvera pas puisque
ce qu'elle sait c'est la finitude de
tout système dissipatif auquel on coupe
l'approvisionnement énergétique vous
rejoignez les propos de Jacques Blamont
dans son livre introduction au siècle
des menaces qui dit
la science et la technologie ne va pas
nous sauver on voit une petite
parenthèse on fait un petit coup de pub
regardez notre toute première vidéo avec
Jacques Blamont
autre question
c'est quoi cette question les gars
[Musique]
alors
vous parlez vous parliez d'aménagement à
développer pour aider la résilience de
nos sociétés de points auxquelles sont
chez vous point d'interrogation
là je pense que la principale affaire la
plus urgente qui est déjà entamée
d'ailleurs par des personnes dont on
recueil les témoignages chez
l'agriculture
et de façon non naïve un exemple
je qualifie dans mon dernier bouquin les
personnes qui se lancent dans la
permaculture par exemple ou qui quitte
la société de quelques façons que ce
soit pour tenter quelque chose de
nouveau de héros vraiment parce que
c'est prendre des risques considérables
pour des tas de raisons et beaucoup se
lancent dans une permaculture qui peut
être alors il y a plein de mythologies
de fantasmes autour de la permaculture
et ça peut être quelque chose à
travailler aucun problème maintenant se
lancer dans la permaculture sur une zone
X en France ces trois quatre cinq ans
pour arriver à obtenir des résultats
première chose le climat lui aura changé
il change très vite il n'est pas sûr du
tout que ces résultats à 3-4-5 ans
soient stables
et en parallèle de ça dans les décennies
qui viennent peut-être plus rapidement
la civilisation peut tomber en
particulier la provisionnement en
énergie et en gaz pour faire des engrais
et des pesticides
une petite aire en permaculture au
milieu de milliers d'hectares
d'agriculture intensive ou d'un pays
complet dont la dominante est
l'agriculture intensive si c'était
l'agriculture intensive s'effondre tous
l'écosystème de la permaculture change
d'un coup et vous avez des gens qui
viennent taper à votre porte pour
récupérer vos tomates déjà ça mais en
plus ce qui aura été obtenu en perma
pourra être totalement perdu parce qu'un
parasite nouveau qui ne sera plus soumis
aux pesticides du voisin qui visait en
industrie va réémettre va réémerger
pardon et
ravagez votre propre culture en
permanence autrement dit vraiment
aujourd'hui là ce qu'il faut engager
c'est une pensée de la complexité
c'est ça c'est d'ailleurs la philosophie
de la permaculture mais la complexité
pas en système isolé alors j'en ai pas
parlé mais c'est ça le talent de
l'esprit humain c'est de réfléchir en
système isolé de coller des trucs
artificiellement isolés du réel et de
les agencer comme ça les arrange c'est
ça une mythologie en fait
donc on va changer un peu de sujet
la question de celle là je la poserais
qu'à la fin et encore c'est pas sûr
désolé
vous avez jamais assisté à des
conférences à l'armée
non du tout j'ai quelques personnes
notamment dans l'association qui
connaissent bien l'armée mais moi c'est
pas mon domaine je voilà je suis honnête
quel personnage
où est-ce qu'on va pouvoir discuter
c'est un sujet qui est archi complexe
mais
mon expertise
comment vous vous avez des enfants j'ai
pas d'enfant vous en voulez alors il se
trouve que je n'en ai pas le désir mais
c'est pas lié aux propos de aujourd'hui
votre frère votre sœur
vous avez des parents qui ont du moins
des copains qui qui comptent peut-être
faire des enfants et
ils connaissent l'ampleur de vos travaux
peut-être vous en avez beaucoup parlé
avec eux comme souvent
comment il vous perçoivent comme un
doigt Yuri un catastrophiste une
Cassandre ou quelqu'un qui est
conscient des choses
est-ce que c'est facile à gérer de
brasser ce type de cheminement
intellectuel
je suis j'ai cette j'ai ce privilège
d'être très bien entouré sur un critère
précis au delà de l'amour et de l'amitié
qu'on peut avoir pour ses proches pour
ses amis c'est la confiance
c'est à dire que même si je suis allé un
peu plus vite en besogne sur certains
points ce soir tout ce que je dis je ne
le dis à aucun moment pour faire peur on
pourrait être malveillant
c'est factuel ou ce sont des inquiétudes
parfaitement légitimes et la confiance
qui était établie fait que le discours
peut être entendu et qu'avec ce discours
là mes proches font des choix qui
peuvent être par exemple antinomiques
avec les inquiétudes mais ce qui se
construit c'est un rapport de confiance
et de préparation c'est à dire que même
si mes proches font des enfants et ils
ont raison
parce que émotionnellement ils en ont
envie donc il faut que tu le fassent ça
se discute pour des tas d'autres raisons
mais ce rapport de confiance est
d'honnêteté
c'est ça qui gardera le lien dans nos
sociétés demain dans toutes les
circonstances est-ce que vous vous êtes
un petit peu organisé il y a certaines
communautés sur Internet vous avez dû
les voir passer les survivalistes
est-ce que vous avez construit votre
petite ferme avec votre petit bunker
avec votre réserve de cartouches vos
plats et aux filles votre petite source
d'eau avec des miradors ou des choses
comme ça alors c'est un point qui a été
pas mal discuté mais en fait on arrive à
peu près tout dans nos réseaux à la même
conclusion avec pas mal de
témoignages et de
récits historique à l'appui probablement
que les personnes qui se seront réfugiés
avec des stocks et si jamais ça doit
s'accélérer je veux dire c'est ça non
plus ce n'est pas une certitude que ça
soit partout très rapide avec une
violence qui émerge bon bref mais
il est possible et c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui s'est passé par exemple pendant le
siège de Sarajevo les premiers les
premières cibles ont été les personnes
qui s'étaient barrées avec des raisins
ça n'a pas duré
elle s'était barricadée sauf que
maintenant ils ont compris personne
n'est au courant de oui cache leur
réserve donc alors ça fait partie d'un
article que je n'ai pas sorti encore
mais ce qui est alors là pour le coup je
suis assez réservé sur l'usage du terme
résilience parce que la résilience c'est
revenir à un état précédent ça
n'arrivera jamais on va s'adapter par
contre il faut penser la plasticité je
préfère le mot plasticité et les réseaux
et ça dans une transition c'est beaucoup
plus efficace et pérenne que de se
barricader chez soi avec des armes un
réseau est beaucoup plus fort parce
qu'il gère les flux
donc il peut approvisionner une ville
une campagne une bourgade isolée qui
subit des
brigandages etc ça c'est quelque chose
de constructif dans une transition
alors une autre question de du chat que
faire à titre individuel une révolution
citoyenne à son échelle est-ce possible
je suis réservé sur le thème révolution
aujourd'hui il se passe je crois en
Espagne des choses intéressantes de quoi
le fait qu'il y a la Guardia civile qui
empêche un référendum intéressant dans
le sens où le peuple réagit enfin il se
passe des choses
un peu comme ça c'est-à-dire que c'est
une région qui est plus riche un peu
comme l'Italie du Nord à l'Italie du Sud
bon bah ils ont décidé de faire ces
sessions parce qu'ils en avaient marre
de payer pour les autres c'est ça
voilà là je saurais pas me prononcer sur
ce point là la révolution est quelque
chose qui me semble encore une fois lié
à l'obtention de quelque chose après
cette révolution ce qui malheureusement
s'est passé en Afrique du Nord
d'ailleurs quelque chose que vous avez
traité ici ou que vous connaissez bien
c'est ce lien entre le pic énergétique
la baisse des rendements agricoles et
puis l'émergence des révolutions et les
déstabilisation politique le terrorisme
etc
on a déployé des réseaux sur place pour
se tenir informé on leur expliquer
comment connecter un PC avoir une
connexion internet pour faire remonter
des informations
on pourrait discuter c'est pas mon rôle
de donner mon point de vue là je vais
vous poser une autre question qui vient
du chat le Pearl classe qui se construit
des lieux d'habitation dans des endroits
les moins touchés par le dérèglement
climatique comment ces gens là voient
l'avenir c'est compliqué il est pas à la
place donc là je peux pas répondre pour
effectivement
la banque de graines qui est en train de
se casser la gueule dans le dans le
permafrost ça c'est une réponse de non
réponse de la technologie c'est une
réponse de nos réponses applicable il
nous reste à peu près parce que vous
avez un train à prendre vous êtes venu
exprès de Lyon pour nous voir il est
19h02 donc on va en rester encore 25
minutes ensemble
on va revenir à notre entretien
la upperclass c'est quand même un sujet
qui est récurrent est-ce que vous pensez
que cette sélection de la Hopper classe
par des comportements les plus
prédateurs les plus courants ou les plus
agressifs
ne baigne pas dans une incapacité à se
remettre en question
alors la capacité à se remettre en
question je ne vois pas en quoi elle
n'est pas distribuée uniformément dans
la population
question de cuit
alors non plus
la problématique problématique à
laquelle on se confronte et beaucoup
plus une question émotionnelle que
l'intelligence même s'il peut y avoir un
lien pour comprendre les aspects
systémiques mais je pense que la
question de la fin la finitude n'est pas
une question liée au QI
je vois pas comment développer là-dessus
du coup par rapport à au lien en Qi
intelligence
vous avez une population qui a un QI qui
baisse
et surtout les problèmes augmentent ils
ont le pied plancher pour payer leurs
factures vous voyez le gamin à l'école
payer des cahiers
des choses normales quoi donc ils ont
pas le temps de s'y intéresser et
surtout ils sont pris dans une dynamique
une accélération
de la problématique qui pour eux
impossible à gérer parce que eux ils ont
pas le temps ils ont peut-être pas aussi
les capacités cognitives de
d'appréhender est-ce que je me suis bien
exprimé les tenants et aboutissants de
la problématique oui mais pas
l'inquiétude inquiétude elle est
uniformément partagée justement étant
toutes les strates de la population en
revanche pour en revenir à la question
de l'effer classe et des inégalités on
appuie par exemple sur cette fameuse
étude Endy qui montrait cofinancé par la
NASA peu importe mais qui montrait que
les inégalités étaient en soi un facteur
d'augmentation des risques
d'effondrement ou même cause
d'effondrement
oui parmi les informations qu'il faut
faire circuler et remonter tout en haut
y compris pour leur faire comprendre que
c'est dans leur intérêt il faut
absolument que la upperclass comme vous
dit en fait elle qui est la plus stupide
probablement puisqu'elle n'a pas compris
que le terreau à sa propre
déstabilisation destitution est en train
de se constituer sous leurs pieds est-ce
que vous avez pas remarqué que cette
peur classe essaye de s'affranchir par
exemple des règles fiscales en créant
des îlots loin de cette corde de de
Manon
va y avoir un fossé cognitif aussi par
l'augmentation le transhumaniste le
transhumanisme qui va être réservé que à
la priorité à ceux qui vont pouvoir
payer
ça va créer d'énormes inégalités elles
sont déjà là et elles augmentent et
elles sont contre-productives pour tout
le monde elles sont idiotes
c'est une mauvaise stratégie pour tout
le monde y compris pour ceux qui pensent
s'isoler de la problématique à court
terme ça marchera pas longtemps et
probablement encore une fois pour
reprendre l'exemple tout à l'heure
qu'ils seront les premiers baisers qui
révoltent et Révolution il y a
même s'ils se barricadent vous
connaissez bien je pense des techniques
d'approche de hacking qui permettront de
les atteindre d'une façon d'une autre
si besoin s'en fait
je
par contre en fait la forme
de l'effondrement on ne la connais pas
c'est l'aspect un prédictible de
l'avenir
ce que je crains c'est que si Révolution
il y a nous soyons tous perdants c'est
pour ça que la promotion que nous
pouvons faire dans la drastia c'est la
bonne intelligence et l'intelligence
d'éviter que chacun tire la couverture à
lui ce qui serait contre-productif pour
tout le monde puisque cela créerait ou
augmenterait les tensions préexistantes
c'est peut-être ma seule utopie pour
être honnête d'accord mais j'aime bien
garder cette naïveté là
le pendant inverse si vous permet de
dormir il faut ça même si je dors très
mal mais ça fait ça peut faire partie de
la réduction de mes insomnies
bien sûr le côté dystopique est
envisageable ou les élites
établiraient une stratégie sur la
bêtification du monde pour se donner
l'illusion qu'ils pourront s'en sortir
je pense que c'est une très mauvaise
stratégie y compris pour eux si vous
vous trompez c'est ce que je dis je n'ai
pas la réponse la forme c'était une
bonne stratégie en fait
de pomper de s'augmenter le plus
possible
nous en faisons partie en fait
gagner 1000 euros en France c'est faire
partie des 10% des humains les plus les
plus riches grosso modo
donc tout ce que vous tout ce que vous
décrivez de stratégie nous sommes
peut-être aussi sans nous en rendre
compte en train de les mettre en place
par exemple en votant pour une
augmentation de l'emprise sur les
ressources à l'étranger militairement
il a été voté cela
nous sommes bien d'accord donc c'est 10%
de l'humanité
mettons peu importe cette
upper classe qui est faite aussi d'une
bonne partie de peuple et qui qui a
participé quantitativement à la
dévastation du monde et peut-être aussi
en train de tabler
sur l'effondrement de la strat en
dessous mais on en revient à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure la
conflictualisation de la réalité pour
l'humain et potentiellement présente à
tous les étages et c'est ce qui
maintient le fonctionnement de la
défausse qui fait que tout le monde
continue de la même façon le même
comportement et ne change rien
lui il nous reste 10 minutes vous voulez
aborder quoi comme sujet vous avez 10
minutes c'est open
j'ai
j'aimerais vraiment que s'ouvre un débat
sur ce que vous avez abordé
faut-il plus ou moins de démocratie
en écho à ce que j'ai décrit d'elle
vous militez pour un Kaiser
faut-il une dictature verte point
d'interrogation un leader point
d'interrogation je vais changer leader
par un Kaiser c'est à dire que dans
toutes les payeurs période troubles de
l'histoire les gens ont réclamé un
Kaiser un leader quelqu'un qui va les
sauver alors on peut rebondir là dessus
la période est tout à fait propice à
l'émergence de pseudo Messie alors ça
les nouveaux gourous les nouveaux coraux
et partout y compris
y compris et surtout peut-être dans le
domaine de du risque d'effondrement
parce que mythologie apocalyptique fin
du monde donc corrisation de la
problématique ce qui est d'ailleurs un
risque
pour le traitement scientifique de la
question
quand vous dites quand vous dites
du moins un débat autour de plus ou
moins de démocratie je vous relance la
vous avez raison c'est pour moi la
nécessité de recoller
le lien entre l'unité monétaire qui
correspond à une unité énergétique et la
destruction de l'environnement qui qui
équivaut à cette unité
et
ôter le bulletin qui est censé
cloisonner ce lien là entre le billet et
la destruction environnementale là
seulement à mon avis nous pourrons
établir des stratégies conscientes
d'adaptation mais tout est à construire
à ce niveau là bien sûr ça demande un
changement de paradigme
il se trouve que pour la première fois
dans l'histoire l'humanité est
confrontée à un risque de fin
uniforme de toutes les communautés
humaines sans parler de faim de déclin
et ça c'est inédit toutes les
civilisations qui se sont effondrées ou
même les tribus qui se sont effondrés
précédemment avait un extérieur donc un
imaginaire ou dans lesquels elle pouvait
se projeter et se dire on meurt quelque
chose se déroulera après pour la
première fois dans notre imaginaire il
est possible que nous intégrions qu'il
n'y a plus rien possiblement après ou
pas d'extérieur pour reconstruire
quelque chose nous allons devoir
reconstruire directement sur les ruines
il faut donc nous reconnecter
émotionnellement à ça
ça doit pas être très simple vous
nuances c'est pas simple alors autre
question de l'Internet est-ce qu'il nous
manque à tous un imaginaire collectif
d'un monde Perrin
c'est la question que je viens de
d'évoquer c'est possible que cette image
génère là soit mis en péril un but avisé
point d'interrogation ah oui
là on a un choix peut-être que ça sera
une forme de conclusion d'ailleurs on a
un choix
pourra débattre du terme de choix
c'est un prédictible ça pourrait être
dramatique il pourrait y avoir de la
violence pour y avoir des horreurs
possiblement
quoi qu'il arrive on peut se permettre
de tenter la dignité
c'est ça fait partie de votre manifeste
au sein de votre association répétez-moi
la phrase c'est anticiper la fin de la
civilisation de la civilisation thermo
industrielle de façon honnête
responsable et digne donc digne ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire justement
réinscrire la problématique
d'aujourd'hui dans dans cette histoire
très longue
d'Homo sapiens c'est respecté tous ceux
qui ont construit ça et qui ont
finalement participé à ce grand angoisse
existentielle c'est ça être digne c'est
regarder l'avenir avec toute l'histoire
et tout ce qu'on porte en nous
d'émotions très dures très positives
et c'est à mon sens quelque chose qui
nous permettra d'éviter de nous taper
tous dessus par exemple
on arrive à la fin ça fait une heure à
peu près qu'on est ensemble la dernière
question c'est pas une question c'est
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations une bouteille à la mer un
périssable sur Internet ou la parole
le j'évoquais dans mon parcours ce qui a
le plus marqué le contenu très abstrait
pourtant de mon travail c'est mon
expérience le contact direct avec la
réalité pour des tas de raisons ça met
beaucoup ça m'est très difficile
aujourd'hui de retourner dans d'aller
dans les champs de travailler la terre
etc
mais c'est ce qu'il y a de plus
formateur à la fois pour l'esprit et
pour l'émotion et c'est ce qui permettra
justement d'ancrer dans la réalité et le
pragmatisme qui évitera les raptus les
explosions psychologiques les les
décompensations psychologiques il faut
absolument retrouver le contact avec la
réalité c'est ça le message pour ceux
qui grandissent aujourd'hui la réalité
c'est la fin de notre émission
j'aimerais que la communauté aille voir
vos conférences sur votre chaîne YouTube
dans le sens où qui est nécessaire de
comprendre votre point de vue en passant
par vos conférences parce que là ça fait
un petit peu comme un cheveu sur la
soupe merci beaucoup non c'est pas merci
beaucoup c'est la structure ality il y
en a plein d'autres gens comme ici il y
a Jacques Blamont il y a même un
documentaire qui qui est un peu
sulfureux mais c'était le documentaire
d'un pote Michael Rupert qui parlait
très bien français et qui connaissait la
Marseillaise la dernière conversation
que j'ai eu avec lui était autour de la
Marseillaise
le nom de votre chaîne c'est
tout simplement
[Musique]
aller compléter les informations pour
pouvoir revoir cette interview et des
crypté entre guillemets les privates
qu'on s'est lancé à gauche et à droite
je vous remercie d'être venu de Lyon
rien que pour ça et c'est fort immeubles
de votre part et on est très content de
vous avoir reçu et puis voilà merci à
vous c'était vraiment un plaisir et je
suis voilà c'est un message très
important qu'il faut prendre avec
sérieux et on l'a parfaitement traité je
vous remercie beaucoup vous reviendrez
pour redéler un petit peu parce que
c'est nécessaire quand même oui on a dit
beaucoup de choses très vite je m'en
excuse si ça c'est un peu entre choqué
mais on refera une émission parce que
ici on n'aime pas le simple et court
parce que sinon c'est le passeport pour
le slogan idéologique pur
vous souhaite une bonne soirée et on va
vous mettre au train merci beaucoup très
bonne soirée merci
[Musique]